so I think the takeaway is that I need
to date guys who literally have no idea
who Jason I think the takeaway is no
more fish oil yeah we are oh hey did you
get all the followers no I even tried
making an ASMR video
what are those Whisperer videos Hey
right ain't natural yeah I actually lost
followers on that video so now I need
ten thousand and seventy three by
tomorrow hey who's the skank
oh my god it's Kobe wanna come hike with
us bitch we got an extra animal onesie
you know hiking in onesies you know how
many photos they're gonna take okay I
gotta go I think you should do something
to my hair cuz their hair is always so
cool I'm just gonna are you but coming
and instigating what no no I just want
to book this miniseries okay bye good
luck on all your dates today see you've
never heard of chase dreams or his music
yeah I don't know that is perfect only
music I listened to his fish seen him
live 700 12 times and then like the
whole uber wreaked of taco salad I'm
like I have to give this guy 5 stars I
feel so bad great sorry 5 stars but guys
right here is very picturesque could we
take a picture here maybe you care
you're seriously cracking me off no I
haven't heard of Chase dreams or fashion
I don't like music hot what do you like
books books I love I love reading books
talking about books but then I was like
instead of just telling her the truth
I'll just let her have it like it
doesn't hurt me you know hey guys what
about this what about this what a funny
image right
imagine scrolling past this me is a hot
cow oh my god a baby bird out here so
nice to meet you congrats again on
getting rescued from
basement you okay can I get you anything
yeah you can knock me out and wake me
when I'm dead
voice troubles what no did you just see
all those awful dates I was on yeah not
a winner in the bunch
no and it's like I just started dating
because I was so consumed with work and
then it just ended up being more work
you know what my sister did I don't my
sister was so fed up with the dating
scene that she posted an ad saying that
she would be wearing a red dress
standing at Madison Square Park holding
a single red rose and she invited any
handsome bachelor to come by sweep her
off her feet she's now been married
eight years nah that is so dumb I would
never do that in a million
yeah okay beautiful right yep so let's
take a picture huh
I said let's take a picture right here
with this beautiful like oh we're just
here for the nature it's no purse Sunday
no post Sunday then why the hell am i
hanging out with you excuse me Cameron
what's happening
Carrie's not being funny
[Music]
are you yeah Wow strong you're gorgeous
so are you I can't believe it I mean you
knew nothing about me
saw an ad in Craigslist II decided to
take a chance on a stranger in status
and spare Park that's pathetic
you're a loser I'm a loser I'm sorry I
have to leave I'm a loser if we're not
taking pictures what's with these stupid
onesies they're comfy not everything we
do is to get a picture Carrie were you
just like using us to leech off our
followers Carrie we thought you like
this for who we are not our work you
call what you do work all you do is get
naked and post pictures and have sex
with each other
we don't have sex with each other what
why don't you
we were virgins and I'm straight and I
used to be fat but now I have two nieces
that's not a thing Drake okay that's the
problem with you guys you don't do
anything I actually do something I act
like what what are you in I'm trying to
do something but the way this business
works is you got to do stupid like
this to even get to that level so I'm
gonna go over here and I'm gonna pose
like a little pouty cow and you're gonna
take a picture and tag me
wait are you filming please don't film
not whose don't trust this thirsty don't
shady camera no bitch at carry no please
don't do that please don't ask
wait I just got a hundred and followers
could you actually tweet that
you